[Musique]
ce soir dans notre séquence ping pong
gersois andré bamberski il va répondre à
une critique de sandrine big lots de
francs soir à propos de ce que l'on a
appelé la sphère kalinka ensuite nous
évoquerons son livre pour que justice se
soit rendu la promesse d'un père sur la
tombe de sa fille c'est chez michel
lafon andré bamberski dont soir bonsoir
donc je vais me permettre de vous
proposer un avertissement pour que notre
conversation se déroule dans un cadre
légal alors nous allons parler ensemble
une affaire qui est en cours
d'instruction ce qui suppose que toutes
les personnes impliquées ils en seraient
d'accord bénéficie de la présomption
d'innocence que ce soit vous andré
bamberski où que ce soit le docteur
didier ther chrome barque depuis 27 ans
vous défendez une thèse concernant la
mort de votre fille kalinka dieter
krombach son beau-père serait
responsable de la mort de votre finir
une thèse qui quand elle affirmé va à
l'encontre de la présomption d'innocence
dès lors si je puis dire nous
utiliserons le conditionnel en ce qui me
concerne comme notre langue d'usagé
alors vous pouvez vous avez à dire bien
dès lors dit est ce que vous avez à dire
sur le sujet déjà je voudrais vous dire
que la sphère n'est pas en cours
d'instruction le docteur krombach par un
arrêt de la chambre d'accusation de
paris d'avril 1993 et est accusé inculpé
on dit maintenant
d'homicide volontaire c'est à dire de
meurtre sur la personne de ma fille
kalinka là il ya une instruction qui est
terminée donc depuis très longtemps et
du fait que chrome bar vient seulement
d'être arrêté en france
il va passer devant la cour d'assises
par contre je précise bien que
tant qu'il n'a pas été condamné tant que
la cour d'assises n'a pas statué il est
présumé innocent alors si on parlait
d'instruction on peut s'y faire
référence à l'enlèvement du dr krombach
qu'il a en l'occurrence est une affaire
qui comprend ce qu'il a réellement
j'ai été mis en examen et cette affaire
d'enlèvement dont je suis
disons présumés accusés et elle par
contre en cours d'instruction donc dans
la tente que les deux juges
d'instruction qui sont co saisis dans
cette affaire terminent leur travail et
éventuellement arrêtent tous les
protagonistes puisque il en reste encore
a arrêté à situer bien maintenant vous
avez donc répondent à sandrine briclot
de france soir elle vous pose une série
de questions très simples très clair
très net auquel je vous demanderai de
répondre si vous voulez bien
depuis 27 ans vous traquer le docteur
combat qu un médecin allemand est ce
qu'on peut pas considérer que c'est de
l'acharnement contre c'est thomas disons
je ne pense pas que c'est de
l'acharnement contre le docteur krombach
donc de ma part
par contre dans ma volonté je suis
effectivement acharné et c'est venu
progressivement parce que avec le temps
j'ai de plus en plus d'éléments sur
qu'ils ont la responsabilité
est donc le l'inculpation de krombach
d'une part dans ce meurtre et surtout
sur les anomalies les dysfonctionnements
les bavures qui ont entaché cette
affaire
disons c'est de la patience de ma part
pour que krombach
soit
définitivement et valablement jugé
devant la cour d'assises alors je vais
donner de date pour qu'on comprenne pas
ce que signifient ces 27 ans qui sont
appelés ici de tracks et le 10 juillet
1982 kalinka bamberski votre est
retrouvée morte au domicile de son
beau-père faut le préciser dieter
krombach ce médecin allemand et dans la
nuit du 17 au 18 octobre 2009 le même
docteur jetair combat est retrouvé pieds
et poings liés à proximité du tribunal
de mulhouse et c'est sa vie constituent
les deux lederlé de cette année deux
dates absolument charnière de cette
affaire sur lequel on aura revenir je
vous en prie à l'evo commandité
l'enlèvement du docteur combat que le 18
octobre en autriche les circonstances de
l'enlèvement du dr krombach restent
troubles est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire plus on nous expliquait par exemple
comment vous avez rencontré les hommes
qui l'ont enlevée et dont deux d'entre
eux sont d'ailleurs incarcéré
aujourd'hui en france il faut préciser
la stat d'abord je précise que
l'enlèvement n'a pas eu lieu en autriche
mais en allemagne dans la petite ville
de scheidegg depuis deux à trois
semaines j'avais pris ma décision pour
réellement faire quelque chose ou même
dans le fond de moi même et donc c'est
tout à fait
occasionnellement que
ce monsieur anton krasniqi s'est
présentée à moi 8 vieux c'est lui qui
est venu à moi et donc qui m'a demandé
si j'étais d'accord pour que disons il
s'occupe du transport de krombach
d'allemagne en france pour que justice
soit rendue c'était pas sa motivation je
pense que c'est plutôt quelqu'un qui est
qui a un but humanitaire ou social son
avocat l'a d'ailleurs qualifié de robin
des bois ce n'est pas du tout un
professionnel
ce n'est pas du tout assez nerveux ce
n'est pas un mercenaire ce qui plus est
ce n'est pas un voyou ni un bandit c'est
pas professionnel voilà ce n'est pas du
tout ce n'est pas du tout un
professionnel est-ce qu'on peut revenir
sur le terme que j'ai utilisé de beau
père c'est-à-dire la situation telle
était la situation de deux roues deux
niveaux enfants effectivement en 1975
la maman de kalinka et moi même avons
divorcé
j'ai eu donc à l'époque la garde des
deux enfants parce que la maman ne
voulait pas et donc quand la sphère
s'est produite mes deux enfants dont
kalinka était en droit de visite chez
leur maman qui était remarié entre temps
avec le dr krombach donc à lindau en
allemagne au bord du lac de constance
justifier l'attitude des justices
française et allemande est ce que vous
pensez réellement que le docteur combat
qu ait bénéficié de protections au plus
haut niveau de ces états que savez vous
de ça c'est absolument réels à partir de
93 94 il y a eu des pressions politiques
qui ont même été concrétisée par écrit
avec des documents dont j'ai les copies
dont je détiens donc tout toutes les
preuves
l'allemagne a exigé et en
94-95
que la france ne fasse pas comparaître
krombach devant la justice française et
en particulier devant la cour d'assises
de paris même par contumace
et après la condamnation par contumace
donc le crown bar en 95 à 15 ans de
réclusion criminelle
j'ai des documents écrits de hauts
responsables de la chancellerie donc du
ministère de la justice français
qui ont ordonné par écrit à monsieur
burgin alors procureur général de paris
qui était donc qu'il y avait donc pour
obligation d'exécuter la condamnation
c'est à dire de lancer des mandats
d'arrêt internationaux contre krombach
dont des ordres écrits de ne pas
exécuter ces condamnations vous avez
transmis ces pièces à la justice pense
que non seulement je les ai transmis
mais je les ai eus de la justice
française je les ai eus à partir de
l'année 2003 2004 lorsque j'ai porté
plainte pour collusion corruption et
entrave à la justice donc contre les
plus hautes autorités judiciaires et
politiques françaises
vous êtes aujourd'hui mise en examen
pour enlèvement vous encourez une peine
de 10 ans d'emprisonnement est
franchement le prix à payer pour que
justice soit rendue à kalinka
aussi c'est un prix à payer je l'assumé
j'ai fait en réalité le travail des
autorités judiciaires
et même politique française donc qui
jusqu'à ce jour attendait en réalité la
fin de la prescription qui va survenir
dans deux à trois ans et donc est ce que
c'est un prix à payer
trail pays je suis prêt à le payer
j'espère qu'il y aura la compréhension
du tribunal correctionnel de mulhouse
est bon comme toujours dans cette
affaire il faut faire des priorités
logiquement le docteur combat qu
incarcéré aujourd'hui en france
devraient comparaître prochainement
devant la cour d'assises de paris
qu'attendez vous de ce nouveau procès ce
à quoi j'aspire c'est que donc krombach
soit réellement condamné pour ce meurtre
pour faire carrément un trait parce que
il n'est pas possible qu'on continue
est ce que vous pourrez faire un trait
si le docteur combat qu est ce qui t
j'espère je pense que si le docteur
krombach est acquitté je l'aurais plus
aucune possibilité judiciaire de
continuer ce combat donc comme je suis
quelqu'un de réaliste et disons
d'objectifs
j'accepterai l'aspect là le verdict non
on va venir
maintenant si vous le voulez bien à
votre livre andré bamberski pour que
justice soit rendue michel lafon alors
on peut se poser la question de pourquoi
ce livre maintenant est ce que c'est
pour poser sur la justice que c'est pour
peser sur l'opinion publique non pas du
tout ce livre je dois le dire et surtout
la réalisation de l'association justice
pour kalinka
qui s'est constitué en 2001 pour ma 6t
pour est en fait
ce livre a été réalisé par les
responsables de l'association justice
pour kalinka
avec bien sûr ma participation donc je
suis à la base de tout le contenu de ce
livre
est donc ce livre est un témoignage pour
que l'électeur c'est à dire l'opinion
publique les citoyens français et
quelque chose à dire d'une manière
d'une manière agréable
est ce que vous croyez pas andré
bamberski d'être un justicier d'être un
modèle malgré vous je dirais que si
si je dois donner mon opinion je dirais
à qui que ce soit
d'abandonner
plutôt que de supporter les souffrances
d'un tel combat alors j'ai posé deux
questions brèves réponses devant elle
est-ce que vous avez un jour penser à
tuer le docteur kamba oui l'idée l'idée
m'est venue à l'esprit plusieurs fois
aujourd'hui quel est le sentiment qui
domine en de la haine de la sérénité de
l'espoir
bien sûr bon là la sérénité je l' ai
acquise bien que ce soit très difficile
l'espoir je les laisse par c'est pour
moi c'est c'est la cour d'assises
je n'ai plus de haine envers krumbach
parce que bon maintenant je sais et j'ai
toutes les preuves du genre de
personnage que c est le sentiment qui
s'émousse et mon sentiment maintenant
c'est que j'ai plus de la pitié pour lui
jusqu'à 7 ce procès de la cour d'assises
qu'autre chose on ne peut pas éprouver
de la haine envers un tel personnage
là bas je voulais vous remercier ans des
bons gars qui je crois que c'est une
affaire qui touche beaucoup de monde on
va suivre avec intérêt les
développements judiciaires et pour ceux
qui peuvent encore lire ce livre pour
que justice soit rendue la promesse d'un
père sur la tombe de sa fille c'est un
témoignage et c'est chez michel lafon
merci et à côté je vous remercie
beaucoup et je remercie par avance les
lecteurs qui auront le courage et la
patience de lire ça mais c'est très
instructif sur
c'est certainement exceptionnelle sur
les dysfonctionnements de la justice
française merci
[Musique]